hey everyone my name is Jake and I've
been playing Animal Crossing for the
past month now and while I have really
been enjoying it there are some things
that are missing so I figured I'd come
with a list of some of the buildings and
characters that I have not seen yet now
I do in a preface that Animal Crossing
is meant to be played for long stretches
of time so they could just not be in the
game yet maybe they show up as you play
or Nintendo could add them through
updates but anyway let's get to it so
the first one up is the art museum in
previous Animal Crossing games there was
a wing of your museum dedicated to
artwork and you can get artwork through
a character named crazy red who would
show up at your town every now and then
and basically he'd sell you things for a
very high price and you'd have to
determine whether or not the artwork was
real or counterfeit I haven't seen crazy
red at all I haven't found any artwork
and so far even though I've donated a
good amount to the museum I haven't
gotten any upgrade for an art museum the
next one here's the roost which was
always a personal favorite of mine it
was basically a coffee shop run by a
pigeon named Brewster now I've been
playing for about a month now I've seen
no signs of him or coffee or anything I
feel like this is something that will
come later through an update at least
that's what I'm hoping for because I
always thought Brewster and the roost
was such a staple of the Animal Crossing
series the next one I have here's dr.
shrunk in previous games he would teach
you different reactions however since
now animals will come up to you and
teach you those reactions I don't really
see why he'd be in the game I doubt
you'll run into him at all maybe they'll
add him eventually but I think he's just
kind of been cut the next one here is
mr. Resetti which is kind of interesting
because he is kind of in the game right
if you call Rescue Services it sounds
like he's the one on the other end who
will help you get out of a sticky
situation I actually have only called
rescue services once mostly because I
wanted to see if I'd be able to see mr.
Resetti
I didn't so I don't think he's in the
game maybe I'll show up eventually but
who knows Jai roids are another thing
that's missing in this game so
technically there is Lloyd of which
whenever you build a bridge or an
incline you donate funds to him and he's
a very good character I do like Lloyd
quite a bit but I haven't seen any guy
roads buried or anything like that it
seems like as of right now gyros are
just not in the game the next character
I have here is Cap'n who would basically
paddle you out to your deserted island
and sing you a tune on your way I don't
think he's in this game because the
Dodos kind of stole his job right
they'll fly you out to deserted islands
where you can catch bugs and fish
pick fruit and what not so I don't think
we'll see him in the same capacity as
before maybe he'll show up as a visitor
at some point through an update the next
character missing we have here is
tortimer now at the beginning of new
leaf he kind of transitioned a lot of
his responsibilities off to you and more
or less retired which is good friend you
know it was getting kind of old however
we haven't seen him at all in New
Horizons I remember during the direct a
lot of people were theorizing that the
tombstone up on the cliff could have
been tortimer that's definitely not the
case though because we found out that
you can just place objects that look
like tombs don't start your Island if
you really want to speaking of Mayors
one thing that's not New Horizons are
ordinances ordinances a new leaf
basically let you tweak how your Island
work two big ones were the late night
and early bird ordinance which basically
changed the hours of all your shops so
if you are gone all day working or at
school or whatever it might be you could
change it to the late night ordinance oh
you could still check out all your shops
and whatnot and see what's available the
next building that's missing is shampoo
DeLand Animal Crossing new horizons you
can customize your hair style and color
through a mirror so it doesn't really
need to be in this game that still begs
the question of what happened to Harriet
who knows maybe we'll find out one day
so the next one I have here is perfect
fruit now this could still be in the
game it could just be that we haven't
found it or we haven't met the
requirements to grow perfect fruit but
new leaf perfect fruit basically was
just fruit that sold for a lot at the
stores there were different ways you
could get it like I said we don't think
it's the new horizons but we haven't
seen it yet maybe when your town hits
five stars perfect fruit start showing
up or something like that
the next character we have here is
Katrina the fortune teller basically
she'd show up on your town and give you
a reading for a small fee she'd tell you
ways to improve your luck and whatnot so
far I haven't seen her so the next
building we have here is the police
station which so far hasn't shown up
which personally I guess I'm kind of
okay with but I do really miss copper
and Booker I thought they were a great
pair and I think they'd add a lot to new
horizons if they were in it so fingers
crossed that one day they will you know
at least swing by our island and say hi
the next character we have here is Rover
which I always thought was kind of a
mascot for Animal Crossing but I guess
not because so far we haven't seen Rover
an animal crossing new horizons in
previous games Rover would more or less
just set up your town for you ask you
where you were headed there you could
name your town and you could answer some
of Rovers questions and that would
determine your looks the next character
we have here is the fashion superstar
Gracie and preview
animal crossing games she would show up
to your town and she would more or less
judge whatever you're wearing and seems
like that role has kind of been shifted
over to label who does show up every now
and then on your town and she'll have
you dress a certain way that she'll
recommend and if you do it she'll give
you a tailors voucher which lets you
pick out anything you want at the able
sisters a building that we probably
won't ever see is the post office mostly
because a lot of those responsibilities
have been shifted over to the Dodos at
the airport but before there was a
dedicated post office building that you
could go to and that's where you had
send letters and do other things like
that it was run by two characters Pelle
and Phyllis I thought they were great
characters haven't seen him so far but
apart from that you could also talk to
Pete who would deliver mail to all the
residents the next building we have here
is retail which was introduced in Animal
Crossing new leaf but is not a new
horizon so far it was run by recent
Cyrus and basically you sell your stuff
to them they could reupholster furniture
eventually but it seems like that's kind
of been replaced by the DIY
customization options in the game
another character here which is a little
bit of a weird one is Joan because even
though we haven't seen her she has been
mentioned in the game most of her
responsibilities have been transitioned
over to Daisy Mae but Daisy Mae has
mentioned Joan so Joan is still alive
and kick'n the next thing we have here
is the happy home showcase which was run
by Digby a lot of what you did and a
happy home showcase was linked to
streetpassed so it kind of makes sense
that that's not in the game I hope maybe
down the line with an update they find
another way to integrate the happy home
showcase because that was a good way to
you know share what your house looked
like with other people anyway those are
some of the biggest things that we
haven't seen an animal crossing new
horizons yet if you found any of this
stuff please please please let us know
because I would love to get it on my
town if there's other things that we
didn't talk about that you miss please
let us know in the comments below and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
[Applause]